weiß nicht was ich mir holen würde ich
finde halt waschbär megacool vorjahr mit
kindern
heja schatz also ich habe mir jetzt ein
haustier besorgt hier kuschelt mit dem
waschbär bekommt seine minecraft tirol
der epischen legende und wie es mit
conny conrad hallo wie gehts hier
mir geht's gut aber irgendwie habe ich
den geheimen plan dass ich kann ihn
verbreiten will den namen conny das
tägliche das hat das hat sie mal
irgendwann eingeführt von einem jahr
oder so und dann hat das keiner gesagt
jetzt mittlerweile sagen dass immer mehr
und das ist richtig klasse das glaube
ich nicht sagen ich darf das nicht sagen
sagt luca oder kaum krasser buka heißt
du jetzt schmucke ja das kann man sich
aber nicht so gut conny übrigens diese
essensausgabe von mir nati finden gegen
nicht genutzt
ja weil ich das ding ich hab einmal von
einer schweinefarm gesammelt und ich
habe meine ich habe einen ender backpack
da habe ich noch sechs noch 46 steaks
die er hasst die elektrik essenzen im
jahr hast du träumst aber was ich dich
auch noch fragen wollte und zwar wenn
ich mit meinem chocobo ganz weit weg
fliegen sagen wenn man ja wie ist das
ändern wenn ich dann zurück will
im spiegel wie im kokon weit weg ja und
dann wird das schoko stehen lassen ja
dann willst du mit dem spiegel zurück ja
du willst dass schoko ball irgendwie
sich zu dem portet ja dann musst du mit
einer show coppélia auf das viech eben
drauf gehen und dann verlor machen und
aber es muss so sein dass der bereich
von wem du dich aus zurück portes als da
wo das stück wo drinsteht geändert wird
und auch der zielbereich geändert ist
von einem eps von 2 die map ja nicht
oder steht der schock über das
eigentlich folgen sollte deswegen ging
es ja auch nicht als mich aufs
stadtgebiet habe das 1 1 statt wege
stehen musste und ich in der neuen stadt
aber der sich überhaupt worte
es musste eigentlich so geschickt über
portal tür machen so sieht das aus ja
das ist einfach mit kommt der pass also
ich glaub ich glaube einfach nehmen die
richtung ich weiß nicht wie viel ich war
überall schon
also ich habe jetzt zwei phoenix fehlt
dann finde ich richtig geil also im
kampf bin ich auf jeden fall op und ich
habe 22
er tauscht das ist richtig geil ich habe
zwei slime konzert tauscht und zwar doch
dafür war ein sexy cool damit gegeben
von roth pilzgerichte werk wolle ja ich
glaube ich werde jetzt einfach in diese
richtung gegeben
lol welt machen so also einfach noch
dabei ist
ich sagte ihm die ganze scheiße die ich
brauche so team aus packe ich mal eben
hier an ich wollte das einfach nachher
was davon wertvoll ist und wird nicht
macht das einfach scheiße ratlos wo ist
mein todes revolver welches ding ich hab
ja eigentlich eine schöne sortierung
also jetzt wirklich alles sortiert bei
mir mittlerweile und dennoch ist
irgendwie das wichtigste immer weg
dieser tolle zudem mit sie abgeschossen
habe es war diese blablabla heinz gar
keine ahnung wo das ist er
diese kann ich mir meine tief dahin
nicht anziehen
jetzt hab ich ja jetzt geht hat aber
nicht jetzt auf chalki bin damit nicht
mega der schnellsten eigentlich einfach
einfach so ein bisschen chillen und so
du hast wieder bei links da twitter
gepostet das heißt du hast schöne frage
ja klar uns war haben wir er ich
verstehe das nicht bei mir aber egal es
funktioniert ich finde sagte valla nicht
ist es auch grad ein bisschen kacke dass
ich ohne ging's los los die fresse
writings wollen wir mitnehmen wenn ich
ein idiot ich auch ich habe extra weiter
potter menschen eine test gemacht mit
der aufschrift pistole und moni
natürlich am anderen ende der menschen
steht und mit komplett gelaufen da ist
natürlich fein sortiert
also meine frage war wenn du in ein
spiel müsst des welches wer das also als
charakter in minecraft oder so geht auch
also wenn werden wir quasi in einem
möglich spiel gefangen werden
würdest du am liebsten gefangen sein
also ich muss ehrlich sagen es ist
tatsächlich minecraft weil minecraft ist
ich hab jetzt mit einem freund darüber
gesprochen
minecraft ist tatsächlich das für mich
das geilste spiel auf diesem planeten
ihr müsst euch das ein ziel ich spiele
bereits seit vier jahren minecraft jeden
tag und es macht immer weiter spaß weil
das spiel
das beinhaltet nichts aber auch alles
ich meine das spiel an sich mit nur
vanilla ist langweilig
alles das was es bietet das ist einfach
es bietet ja alles ich meine man sieht
es an den servern
das heißt es werden ms kann battlefield
sein wenn man da die capture the flag
weiß ich was hat es kann auch ein
shooter sein indem man einfach dann
bestimmt noch drauf machte man dann also
ein zielfernrohr was weiß ich was es
kann trotzdem ein aufbauspiel sein sowie
siedler
es kann ein multiplayer sein es kann
single player sein man macht dass man es
ist das aller geilste nicht wirklich
einfach so gerne hier mal hatte keine
sorgen
man baut einfach nur seine dias ab und
baut sich sein haus geistesleben natur
sehr poetisch du ja weil sie nicht also
minecraft an sich wäre natürlich schon
mega geil wenn man so da drin wäre weil
es halt einfach ich bin mal sagen es ist
quasi so du kannst halt alles machen
du bist halt quasi jetzt sage ich mal
nicht gefangen so wie das halt
beschrieben ist was ich allerdings auch
mal ganz cool fände sitzen nicht
minecraft wer wäre würde ich sagen gta
also gta 5 gta das interessiert mich
jetzt aber ja weil das ist genau das
gleiche leisten openworld du kannst
richtig richtig viel machen wie du
gemeint ist in minecraft gibt es
verschiedene spielmodi du spielen kann
sind gta kannst du mit dem auto doch wie
würdest du wirklich hingeht ihr erleben
wollen wurde dann auch sterben kannst du
kannst in minecraft auch sterben ja aber
nicht so sehr geht ja aragon augen
pädagogen alt du bist einem singleplayer
dann würde ich mich auch für nehmen da
und nicht so bullen mäßig wind so viel
aluminium na das ist mega krass aber
sonst denke ich wenn sie würdigt
benehmen aber ich denke wenn es jetzt
nicht
minecraft dann auch nicht gta wäre hätte
ich mega bock auf sowas wie
es ist den street oder oder prince of
persia oder sowas find ich glaube ich
richtig richtig geil was ich mir immer
erträumt habe ist ich war gerne auch in
dragon ball drin gewesen
dre noch gas beim mega drive aufhören so
einen lappen weg release oder so damit
wir keine superkräfte hat oder so es ist
einfach nur geil weil dragonball du hast
superkräfte kannst fliegen in meiner
selbst diese wie ist nochmal die nicht
wie sondern doch die swine ich keine
ahnung ich habe die saison pro hand die
freunde da war da wo dragon ball z
anfing er ging zur schule und sie konnte
gar nichts als normalo und dann hat er
je das fliegen bei das heißt jeder
lappen sogar eine frau jeder schüler
kann aber auf jeden fall jeder kann
irgendwie fliegen lernen die man nur
dieses china was zum kuranyi auf
beigebracht hat beherrscht kann fliegen
das wäre so geil alter stell dir vor du
nach fünf minuten zur schule war ich
gerade in seinem doofen tower hier aber
der ist irgendwie schon zu ende
das war's also ich brauche wirklich kev
vielleicht kannst du mir weiterhelfen
ich brauche auf jeden fall miniatur
herzen und elektrik essenzen also
electric ist tanzen findest du
hauptsächlich auf schiffen
das heißt kannst du so ein höhen
eigentlich vergessen
dafür musst du einfach weit weg das habe
ich auch gemacht auf schiffen habe ich
in einer folge glaube ich gemacht
dadurch 13 stück gesamt an das war in
einer stunde vom live stream aber
bereits in lexington gesammelt
das findest du da miniatur herzen
findest du am besten in der mob fahren
wirklich ob in der abfahrt
ich hab nur in der mod versammelt sehen
hab ich dir auch voll das ist so wie
wenn man die frist um haushalt und man
sprintet so normal dass es so langsam
ich kann noch gar nicht mehr springen
weil ich kann es mehr haft
ich dachte schon so aber diese freiheit
sachen dieser arme das ist schon cool du
kannst einfach über wasser laufen und so
gefällt was ich fahren wollte und zwar
viele haben mir die tipps gegeben cap
wenn du wirklich hier ich muss das dicke
pisten zu bauen damit normalen streams
wie weil die sonst ja nicht existieren
wurde mir gesagt sogar viermal in
festungen und wurden und sowas um das
stück bestens zu suchen war erinnerst du
dich vielleicht dann irgendetwas an
wurst reichen irgendeiner brocks dicky
pisten oder so gesehen hast weiß was
meine ja klar ja was für eine art von
trauerfeier in der letzten folge gesucht
und waren solchen burgen kinder und ich
dachte mir aufkommen
die finde ich ja ganz leicht aber
schnellstens auch fragen alter habe die
gar nicht leicht gefunden
doch gar nichts weiß kann auch nicht in
welchem boden gibt es einen stick pisten
ich gehe mal so ein schiff hier hoch und
kogler elektriker seite sind also wenn
du es die pisten sie ist ich reihe ich
schreie einfach einpacken
so warte hier packen jetzt einen ganzen
sache nein ich brauche jetzt so viel
aluminium er richtig schön hier 15
effizienter sondern eine viele haben
hier wieder das problem ist einfach nur
und frag ich habe keine fakten der
wahlperiode und da mal dass die
lichtqualität im video verdienten aber
dafür kann ich in der höhle dann was
sehen aber hier ist eine hürde da sind
bestimmt ist ein 2 nein ich bin auf
schiffen das war so ein schiff ohne
gegner weiß einfach nur ein schiff nein
leitern klettern alter also wir fressen
die kiste
richtiges ganz kurz ob zwischen spreche
aber ich habe das gefühl dass gefreut
texture pack ist mag ich nicht helfen
heißt ja gar sechs ja ist auch so ist ja
auch so spex ist soll er auch dunkel
sein fliegt um die durch die welt
so war bei mir da sind ja du kennst ja
dass wenn bei diesen festungen und so
meint gerade bei einem schiff ach so da
sind die monster nämlich so von wegen in
spawnen und die spawnen bei mir einfach
gar nicht ist verrückt ich kann auch mal
gucken ein bisschen eine neue frage gibt
das hättet ihr gerne als haustier kev
wird sie gerne als auszählung also ich
weiß ich werde mir ein haustier besorgen
das werde ich aber jetzt nicht so breit
machen und zwar ein hund ich finde
bundes muss natürlich viel arbeit
reinstecken
ja schon aber hunde sind einfach geil
katzen kann ich gar nicht ab er kann
also doch racke also arrogant von wegen
ja ich gleiche mich trotzdem kann sich
nicht auf alten gibt es eine stelle in
den nacken und so nach dem motto sind ja
und hunde sind halt so so freundlich
dabei muss man die lieben dich auch und
so das hat mir gesagt das ticken
erwiesen als irgendwie eine katze war
einem raum und
dann ist das herrchen halt gegangen und
dann war die katze hat kein bisschen
anders die wir hat damit den anderen
personen die im raum war gespielt und so
was alles egoisten ja und bei dem rund
war es so dass er uns so gewählt hat und
solchen weg war
es ist halt schon noch so ein gewisser
unterschied also ich würd mir auf wenn
schon hund holen und ein wenn ich erst
mal wasser bin es ja doch jetzt geht es
so wo sind denn hier noch schiffchen ist
eine verdammte hölle
also was ich mir holen würde wäre eine
hohle irgendwann wird einfach ist
wie also natürlich jedes jedes haus hier
dann spruch arbeit und so aber ich denke
auch gehört nicht nur das geilste
eingefunden sind echt geile tiere aber
ich denke die zeit hätte ich nicht so
ist wie gesagt ich das später wenn ich
dann ein eigenes haus oder so habt dann
geld auf jeden fall 100 dazu
das war hier dass wir immer so leuchtete
minuten aus alter wenn ein eigenes haus
hast ja ein eigenes haus habe später
dann wird zu sagen dann stell mir ist
ein super spieler mit frau und kind so
kinder die mit hund aufwachsen dass noch
kein alter der kinder die mitunter faxen
sind doch aufgeschlossen hat wird auch
bewiesen dabei dass ich hatte nie einen
hund bewertung abgeschlossen
ja natürlich nur das sind halt kommen
besser klar an der gesellschaft
irgendwie sowas hab ich da mal gehört
also ich denke ich würde mir auch wenn
ich zeit hätte würde ich mir auch ein
und holen das werde ich mein
lieblingstier so makaber sonst ja
irgendwie sowas weise nicht ich hätte
echt in die box so was hätte ich denn
endlich den bock
die haben wie viele ob sie sind ohio h
verpisst euch mal ja weiß nicht was ich
mir holen würde ich finde halt waschbär
megacool vorjahr wäre das nur schwer mit
kindern
herr ja schatz also ich hab mir jetzt
ein haustier besorgt hier kuschel wissen
mit dem waschbecken ich an die kinder
das seht ihr was wir haben wollen und
warum also weißt du was ich trocken
müssen zu chillen
ich pushe mich an ein wenig echt mega
cool war verpiss dich du blöde spiel
das kann nicht sein ich finde einfach
wirklich keine stücke bis das projekt
pisten komme dieses dieses rollte eine
ganze kg breuer gar nicht so bräunig und
sich endlich mal hier das nehme ich mit
und die diamant nehme ich mit und jetzt
gehen die oberste sind wir schon ganz
oben noch gar nicht vertrage ich den
hier schon wieder schlafen breite
plattform runter du menschenskinder mann
mann mann mann mann
ich erinnere doch wieder das texture
pack enthalten ist oder ein gewöhnlicher
kenne gar nichts immerhin holt ja ich
hab ich auch von alex gehirn typisch
scheiße aus alter wirklich übel scheiße
ist also ich hab mich so daran gewöhnt
minecraft mit shader und anständigen
text perfekt zu spielen das wenig
minecraft zwar müller sehe ich einfach
nur fast kosten möchte ja so geht es mir
auch mittlerweile also ich komme immer
noch nicht doch klar geht schadet
amüsanteste und anhänglich der haustür
was du dir wünschen möchte ist ja also
waschbär junge etwas spezielles ich
nehme die spinne aber die mit einem
leguan gekreuzt wurde
du hast jetzt angriff hier ist jetzt
schon wieder dieser bösen mob 49 seine
kiste ohne luft gegangen wie ich ihn
hasse ich höre die sterben du bist du
enttäuscht nein ich muss mal schnell
nach oben laufen 1 1 bevor das alles
zusammenbricht
ich weiß gar nicht alle haben hier ist
okay aber ich brauche das ja ich folgte
am abend gesagt soja findest du überall
bei den burgen steig die pisten ist die
zweite folge jetzt wo ich nur um fliege
und keines die pisten findet alle drei
tut mir leid cap von einer ton bricht
zusammen
so ich mag jetzt eben ganze sache mein
rucksack die ich gerade ergattert habe
auf seinem river plate so dass güter
ball jetzt gar nicht alle minimalen ich
hier die befristung höhe brauchen wir
nicht dich auch nicht so dass ich diese
schuhe hier wieder an und dann geht's
los
dazu wartet jetzt hab ich weiß was die
gewissens waren ja wo weißt du wo wir
beide unterwegs waren da diese sandfalle
war ich fast erdrückt wurde
weißt du das noch gesagt kenntlich
schaut will die frei käfig schaut würdig
wo war diese weil das war ja so eine
pisten konstruktion sozusagen das hat
dann fallen lassen
er wurde nicht ausgelöst einfach weil du
draufgetreten bisher müssen die pisten
seien wie das davor zurück erhalten
haben ja schon einen boden oben ist das
weiß auch ganz genau dass es spannend
nicht hier an am morgen
unglaublich jetzt gerade halb eins hier
brauche die bis bissig hat voll keine
ahnung wo das war war das vielleicht
wenn man aus der stadt raus läuft
richtung wo dieses portal ist wo man
rauskommt dass wenn du älter bist und
ausländer raus gehst da nähe bei diesem
portal so nah
das baut erstmals ein pirat zu in der
wand stirbt einfach schön weil maradona
schaden oder
ich schaue mir so ein teil nach die ist
da kommt schon die schüler über 18
minuten und das nächst alle sagen kämpft
diese form servers kleines hab sogar
extra
ich habe schon so viele tanks unter
unserer stadt ausgegraben in der ganz
tiefen tiefe kann ich ja mal ganz tiefe
tiefe meiner dem feuer ganz ganz tiefen
tiefe ist so und das portal war nichts
weil ich berate des servers aber glaube
ich im arsch ist durch die ganzen
abfallen weiß ja das kann echt sein
es kommt ja auch so wenn ich fliege
jetzt baut ja kein einziges monster weiß
wir sind keine kisten darauf auf diesem
schiff stabil genug hat auch hier
perfekt aber noch nicht so viel kann
fast nicht sehr alter wie geil da denkt
man sich so juhu und schiff und unser
volk ist vorbei weil es aber ein cooles
biom wo ich jetzt gerade aufzulaufen
aber es gut aber es ist echt cool mit
diesen tatsachen dass ich einfach übers
wasser halle auf sap backend ball
fenster nicht ist er ja doch ich hab da
war jetzt nicht so wirklich gesucht aber
ich bin jetzt hier im palast gottes ja
das habe ich aber auch schon gehört
da bin ich jetzt drin ok krass das ist
ja ein cooles ende auf jeden fall wie
diese folge werden auf jeden fall noch
eine aufnehmen die dann dementsprechend
morgen kommt und dann würde ich sagen es
euch gefallen hat lassen bewertung da
wenn nicht dann trotzdem und wenn ihr
gut seid dann schreibt auch in die
kommentare was eventuell will mal so
drüber reden können und er wohl endlich
claims finde oder verkehrslärms findet
oder wie ich ganz schnell an
die miniatur jahren kommen in der
lokhalle krieg ich dir nicht traurig
aber sonst nicht sagen tschüss macht's
gut